east of pour sa mère toujours et pour
les enfants malades qui l'a découvert à
l'hôpital veut nager plus que l'année
dernière partira dimanche à 5h30 ou 6
heures du matin durocher
on ne peut pas toucher le rocher on va
passer juste devant le rocher du diamant
a regagné schoelcher un après a priori
8h08 heure de neige
quand je lui demandais satisfait pas et
8 heures de nage
de toutes les façons aubin je le fais
plus que l'année dernière
l'ingénieur à la rigueur 5 5 km enfin
quatrième et et des poussières c'était
pas grand chose donc cette année je me
veut souffrir au même moment et pour les
enfants c'est ça son raisonnement et ils
demandent de venir
pas seulement venus le féliciter pour
son exploit mais devenir quelque part
encouragé ses enfants malades et le
demander d'avoir espoir pour pouvoir
guérir et étendre un avenir meilleur
dirigeant sportif c'est formidable mais
en tant que président je suis inquiet
gérés à temps son arrivée à chercher
avec impatience roulage pourrait dire
ouf c'est fini il est arrivé à bon port
souhaitée au début diminuer la distance
réduite maninona no n'est pas question
de diminuer la distance
le président reste quand même inquiet
paul ii faut être honnête faut le dire
qu'en est il de sa préparation
sa préparation avec son entraîneur
julien pas nouvelle c'est bien passé
donc il semble prêt avec les
professionnels de la mer on a pu
regarder un doigt ou pas c'est pour
essayer de gagner un peu de temps et on
espère que la météo sera avec moi et les
courants aussi pourquoi pas d'accord et
que les courants construire le sont pas
trop forts